good morning Hank it's Thursday August
16th which means that I only have 8 days
left to be young Hank today I'm rocking
the albino squirrel Preservation Society
coming to you out of Texas everybody
knows that albino squirrels are the
Nerds of squirrel them and so it falls
to us to protect them I got a lot of
hair it's almost like I'm making up for
not having hair somewhere else Hank
before we get to the end of my
punishment I'd like to do a kind of
two-part retro edition of brotherhood
2.0 retro item number one the
Brotherhood 2.0 book club is back that's
right Hank after months of delay I am
finally reading deep economy by Bill
McKibben review to come shortly but so
far I like it retro item number 2 the
evil baby orphanage Hank the evil baby
orphanage is like evil baby Rasputin no
matter how hard you try you can't kill
it just a little joke for all the
Russian history nerdfighters Hank I
don't know if you know this but
yesterday was the anniversary of the
death of noted evil lady baby Queen
Randolph alone Oh Hank I don't wanna
brag but I just said noted evil lady
baby really really well this news came
to my attention by a secret sisters
Katie and Liz who made Queen random
Valona a wonderful happy deathday cake
Hank I haven't had a lot of time to
think about the evil baby orphanage in
the last couple of months because I've
been doing nothing but working on Paper
Towns but Hank I want you to know that I
still think the evil baby orphanage has
tremendous potential as some kind of
creative project and I think that the
nerdfighters are doing a great job in my
pants of talking about it on to my
punishment Hank in order for you to
understand the difficulty involved in me
licking a cat I have created this
helpful diagram over here you will see
people in the world who own a cat here
you will see people I know and here you
will see people in Indianapolis does
that say people or pupal as you can see
Hank there are some people in
Indianapolis who I know and there are
some people in Indianapolis who own cats
and there are some people I know who own
cats but there's no one I know in
Indianapolis who owns a cat and therein
lies the dilemma fortunately for us Hank
there is a fourth circle nerdfighters
there are nerdfighters who live in
Indianapolis there are nerdfighters who
own cats and there are nerdfighters I
know that's the ultimate circle so
thanks to the generosity of nerdfighter
mayor or Mary ma I re mayor
I don't know that nerdfighter who is of
course made of Awesome hooked me up with
some people in Indianapolis who have a
cat named Toby which I am going to go
lick this afternoon like I think it says
something about the great people of the
city of Indianapolis that perfect
strangers like Jen and Dave would
welcome me into their home and let me
lick their cat Hank that's Toby and here
are Toby's wonderful owners hey hey
maybe on the head maybe on the head he
won't notice you all right Toby this is
nothing personal but it's just real
quick okay let me get a tongue shot the
UH the cat has been wick tank and my
punishment is finished and I'll see you
tomorrow anyway Hank I'm extremely
grateful to all the nerdfighters in
Indianapolis who offered to help me find
a way to lick a cat because my backup
plan was to go into Petsmart and be like
hey do you mind if I look at that kitten
and then they'd give it to me and I'd be
like and then I'd run